a cornered president
is a dangerous president it's at those
moments my view is that they're the most
dangerous moments
the concern about nuclear weapons is
emerged because Russia's effectively
losing on the battlefield what we're
seeing now is Russia in a dire situation
with few conventional choices at its
disposal but it's still a huge power and
it's still a huge part because of its
nuclear weapons
[Music]
yeah
everybody's talking about this Putin is
unstable he doesn't value life like we
do and he's a Loose Cannon and he has
few options
regardless of whether those things are
true
the point is though that he is also
worried about his own life he's also
worried about the lives of all Russians
because everything would stop
no one's going to survive a nuclear war
[Music]
if he was to use these weapons he's left
with only a few options you strike a
Ukrainian Target
and if you do which one it's not going
to be a city because that would invoke
immediate massive nuclear response
as a psychological blow to the West
you might detonate something over say
the Black Sea and
just remind everyone as he's retreating
remind everyone that we have this and
we're willing to use it
there is a third option that they test
on their own soil
in an old testing grounds in the North
Nevada is Emilia where they used to test
the nuclear weapons just to remind
everybody of the power of these things
in his calculus he has to try and figure
out how to ward off complete failure
with the possibility of you using
nuclear weapons
the problem with nuclear warfare is if
you get it wrong everybody dies
[Music]